ravi de vous avoir jean-luc ravi de vous
recevoir comme tous les invités vous
avez un slogan de la dass aux strass
ouais ça pourrait être aussi la d'astres
en univers impitoyable
jean louis aubert
un nouvel album illustré au stade de
france le 18 mai prochain avec vos potes
de la tournée star 80 on va en parler
mais avant votre portrait par stéphane
blakowski serge
1952 jean luc lahaye mai à paris six
mois il est placé à la dasu il grandira
entre l'orphelinat et les familles
d'accueil pas 17 ans il devient ouvrier
ajusteur mais son rêve d'être chanteuse
16 à 6 mois par la case prison pour une
histoire de potes pour voler lui tire la
carte chance en rencontrant d'aix da
dans un bar c'est elle qui lui permettra
d'enregistrer ses premiers 45
1982 c'est l'année de son premier tube
quatre ans plus tard le voilà le numéro
1 du top 50 avec une chanson écrite pour
sa fille
non
et c'est pas tout jean-luc publie aussi
un bouquin pour raconter son enfance qui
sont un million d'exemplaires bref il
devient la star des années 80 à tel
point que lorsqu il inaugure son
association pour les orphelins
mitterrand vient jouer au baby foot avec
lui le sommet est atteint 87 lorsque tf1
lui confie un grand show télé à son nom
la haie d'honneur
1990 changement de décennie le vent
tourne pourtant luc cellulose album ne
vendent pas du cookie fort des
compagnies et véronique mais bon dans le
temps a vu d'autres c'est pas le genre à
scotcher à battre 2000 nouveau siècle
nouvelle vie jean-luc lance une boîte de
nuit le but 8-7 board d'aubervilliers
qui va devenir la boîte mythique une
heure de paris en 2002 booba est
impliqué dans une fusillade dans le
quartier les flics rapide avant la faire
là où ça se complique c'est qu'à force
de traîner en boîte et des jeunes gens
lui été condamné en 2007 puis en 2015
atteintes sexuelles sur mineurs ça
n'empêche pas de poursuivre les tournées
pour les nostalgiques des années 80 qui
eux ont un peu vieilli
2019 jean luc lahaye n'a presque pas
changé toujours mince pas un cheveu gris
le temps n'a guère de prise sur lui il
est toujours à fond et c'est pour ça
qu'il est le soir cheikh el voilà
et jean michel était aussi un hymne à
temps
animateur pour les genres traduction
s'appelait la haie d'honneur était
diffusée tous les vendredis soirs de
1987 à 1988 sur tf1 qu on va regarder
moi j'ai viré de bord je me suis tanné
la fois puis
mais
leicester
wacogne turler
est
ce que tu peux le remercier
il chante l'amour l'amour l'amour est
toujours l'amour on m'a dit qu'il qu'il
défendait le problème des ghettos à new
york est ce vrai
yvn69 et show d'adieu
liu huaqing tourelles pipeline de
carottes new york
los angeles
[Applaudissements]
depuis vous avez des l'icône est quand
même un peu
ça s'améliore en tous les cas ce qu'il
faut dire aussi qu'on n'a pas dit c'est
que c'est francis bouygues lui même qui
vous avez engagé à l'époque c'est
absolument lui même il m'a reçue chez
lui avec mon producteur à l'époque
s'adresse à mon producteur en pensant
que c'était moi
il a même obligé à chanter en refrain de
papa chanteur voilà moi je suis content
et les pointes la maison monia je vous
le donne l'argent lui kleiber soir
bonsoir vous êtes un chanteur rebelle
êtes un fan de moto et comme vous êtes
fait tout seul on peut dire vous êtes un
motodidacte
donc on vous propose une interview
au
virois
alors je vois une première question si
vous deviez en sortir un nouvel album
enfin une nouvelle version de femmes
mais une version 2019 quel serait le
sous titre ce serait femmes tommy tout
ça me prend la tête femme cité vieille
passe ton chemin ou femme citée trans ça
me va aussi bobin la réponse numéro
trois c'est étrange
et parfois de coluche qui a un jour
affirmé qu'il avait essayé un peu tout
pic finalement il revenait aux femmes
parce que le reste lui avait pas
tellement plus vous avez essayé ou pas
n'ont pas encore boîte de nuit tous les
chats sont gris non pour thor à l'époque
c'est pas les occasions qui manquaient
de ce passionné parce qu'avec les
garçons avaient une relation assez
particulière c'est surtout une relation
d'amitié c'est un peu vos frères de sang
d'ailleurs on voulait savoir ce que
c'est vrai que vous vous taillader les
veines pour sceller des pactes d'amitié
absolument je le fais mais nous montrer
serein à quoi
elle voyez combien deux frères deux sans
trois ouais je suis prêt à faire un
quatrième serait de ce qu'est un ami et
un frère offertes par la nature et moi
je suis toujours prêt à rencontrer un
frère de son et une femme de plus de 60
ans c'est possible ou pas oui bien sûr
elles proviennent surtout quand une
certaine heure page est très très fort
alors qu'est ce qui vous gêne le plus
qu'on pense que vous allez coucher avec
dalida qu'on pense que vous êtes le
frère de brigitte lahaie on compense que
vous êtes le fils caché de mitterrand
aïe aïe aïe non alors dalida j'ai vécu
dans sa maison pendant cinq ans je la
considérais vraiment comme une grande
soeur et elle elle me considérait comme
un gamin comme tu me venait d'avoir 18
ans et pas vous j'avais cet âge là et un
jour j'ai osé dire à dalida tu sais je
crois que j'ai envie de chanter on était
tous les deux allongé au soleil sur la
terrasse elle m'a regardé jetaient à sa
droite elle m'a dit oh mon dieu
surtout pas ce métier
on avait connu surtout avec votre maman
qui vous emmener petit dans le métro
pour baptiser des gens avec une bible
heureux comment vous avez vécu ces
moments bas pas très bien parce que je
la voyais marcher au pas de charge elle
même chercher à la dass et marcher au
pas de charge dans le métro avec un sac
rempli de bible et elle prêchait dans le
métro et le faisait m parfois des gens à
genoux dans le métro en les baptisant
les choses comme ça je l' ai vu insulter
d'autres personnes qui l'écoutait pas et
je les ai vus surtout distribué en une
heure tout ça paye et maintenant vous
avez quel rapport avec la religion à
cause de ça je suis resté très croyant
j'ai été élevé par un prêtre le père du
plessis qui a lui-même baptisé méfie
donc je suis resté très très croyant et
et lorsque je j'ai envie de de soulager
ma peine ou les péchés que j'ai commis
je m'arrête dans une église çà et là au
hasard de dérouter puis du misano moment
des infractions pour vous c'est conduire
trop vite conduire sans permis ou
conduire une voiture volée
aucune des trois mois je conduis très
très vite on vient à deux qu'ils ont dit
qu'ils sont déjà arrivées vous êtes déjà
conduit sans permis oui bien sûr dont la
voiture de parce qu'avant il ya des
chauffeurs de ça j'étais chanteur
légendaire je rappelle cette anecdote
c'est que j'étais engagé en un quart
d'heure par roland petit rond petit
était directeur du casino de paris il
m'a engagé en un quart d'heure m'a
demandé si nous permis je n'avais
absolument pas j'ai dit oui et je me
suis retrouvé au volant à la fois d'une
alfa romeo qui était la voiture de zizi
jeanmaire de tous les jours et de la
rolls quand c'est elle et des soirées tu
vois et un soir alors que je l'avais
raccompagné à l'aéroport pour aller à
marseille parce qu'il dirigeait et
ballet de marseille je suis rentré avec
mes potes j'ai pris la rolls et on a été
en brun gars à montmartre et on s'est
retrouvé à 12 je crois entassés dans la
rolls et j'ai loupé le virage de la rue
gabriel j'ai foncé droit dans un
immeuble à tel point que le choc a été
tellement violent que les vitres se sont
brisées de l'immeuble
la voiture avait d'abord à 90 degrés et
lorsqu'on est rentré dans la cour gib.a
va lâcher une mauvaise nouvelle ils ont
vu la rolls sous le lampadaire on aurait
une sculpture de césar une régression et
j'ai été remercié les médias oui
d'accord a été remis
vous avez aussi eu des démêlés avec la
justice black ou en parler vous avez été
condamné en 2007 pour avoir eu des
relations avec une mineure de moins de
15 ans vous avez aussi été convoqués
pour corruption mineur va moi j'ai juste
une simple question comment est-ce que
vos filles ont justement vécu vos
démêlés avec la justice a très bien
alors vous me parlez de cette première
affaire la fille a fini par avouer
qu'elle mentait sur son âge et en boîte
de nuit à 3 heures du matin une fille
que faire la différence entre une fille
de 15 ans 16 ans 18 ans d'un temps
suffisant encore aujourd'hui incapables
donc l'a reconnu d'ailleurs vos enfants
comment ils ont vécu ça va très mal
elles ont eu honte de vous pas non non
non non non je savais je viens de nulle
part je suis l'arbre qui est le
principal j'espère que je me rappelais
de petites branches et mes fiches sont
les premières branches elles sont très
très fier de porter mon nom
[Applaudissements]
question la galère que les bulls est
d'avoir un dentier d'avoir une pirogue
ou des
perruques ou d'abord une hanche
artificielle à la perruque de la nature
moi m'a été très généreux avec mon âge
je serai je veux remercier ben oui te
regarder non non on pourrait regarder
quand j'ai tous mes cheveux encore j'en
ai enlevé
savez au but les avants voilà non non
non je ne saurais horreur de porter une
perruque le reste
les corrections de ne rien rater de in a
l'habitude abonnez vous mettez un pouce
bleus